no
[Música]
básicamente vengo hay que contarles un
poquito la historia de cómo fue el
inicio de nuestro emprendimiento nuestro
proyecto y fue empezó todo en nueva york
que tuve la dicha de viajar en un verano
del 2015 cuando mi primogénito todavía
estaba en vientre apenas tenía seis
meses de embarazo y bueno todas las
personas que han tenido la dicha de ser
padres y que están han estado en ese
proceso en algún momento saben que las
mamás están en un tema constante de
tener que ir al baño en todos lados
entonces bueno caminando por ahí es
tuvimos que entrar en uno de los
comercios más grandes las condes de
comida rápida más grande del mundo que
era un mcdonald's que en pleno times
square que estaba súper súper full y lo
que nosotros queríamos era utilizar el
baño para que ella pudiese bueno te
estaba con ese tema y al final
dentro de todo lo que es una cadena tan
grande como mcdonald's que tiene sus
puntos de venta en eeuu que obviamente
es una de las ciudades más grandes
también del mundo y el nivel de
tecnologías que tienen tanto anses los
puntos de ventas pasan súper rápido
tienen estas máquinas de autogestión
donde tú puedes pedir pagar que
realmente son bastante veloces pero
bueno contiene sus tardamos unos 20
minutos en pagar para que nos prestaran
el baño porque era una era un requisito
el tema estaba en que en ese momento me
di cuenta y empezó una especie de
obsesión con un factor al que no podemos
controlar pero que sí podemos tal vez
sacarle provecho que es el tiempo
entonces bueno en ese momento empezó
como fue con el momento eureka no no y
dije bueno porque no existe una
aplicación que me permita apenas entró
al comercio que automáticamente de
manera universal cualquier tipo de
comercio la aplicación se convierte en
ese comercio y me permita pedir pagar e
interactuar lo que sea que vaya hacer
con el comercio esa interacción que sea
automática y rápida no entonces bueno me
fui con esa idea y pasaron como tres
años
hasta que bueno decidí sabes que voy a
empezar con este proyecto entonces bueno
diseñé en una especie de láminas más o
menos de este tamaño todos los ejemplos
de lo que podría hacer esa aplicación
con los diferentes comercios o kate y me
servía en el diseño y se el lobo que es
una pena de que se te pago directo que
justamente el punto de intersección
entre el usuario y el comercio y bueno
dije bueno con estas láminas voy a
empezar a vender no necesito un equipo
de desarrollo porque ya tenía una buena
idea conseguí una tecnología excelente
que permitía esa comunicación que es la
microlocalización a través del bluetooth
vélez y empecé con las ventas a ver qué
podía hacer con esos famosos mantelitos
que ya le vamos a contar porque se llama
los mantelitos y el primero que convencí
para que se uniera al equipo es que
actualmente es mi socio y mi hermano
axel extras y de esa manera bueno marque
yo nos conocimos
este empezó con el tema de los manteles
porque está efectivamente un restaurante
y colocamos los manteles vimos el tema
de dos los verticales que podemos atacar
con la tecnología bluetooth® vélez y
bueno eso de realmente los manteles fue
algo que nos abre las puertas al mundo
tecnológico al mundo transaccional y nos
abrió puertas a nivel de reuniones con
bancos reuniones con switches que fue
muy importante para realmente que
empaparnos a todo lo que es el producto
y el proyecto no estamos atacando no me
acuerdo que obviamente el detalle el
dinero era algo súper importante hicimos
unos paquetes de inversión de unos
montos bajó un monto medio y un monto
alto y queríamos hacer algo tipo como un
crowdfunding para levantar capital y
sabemos que para levantar capital
semilla en este país es súper complicado
y eso era mediados a principios del 2018
y realmente se avecina va una crisis
económica bastante fuerte bueno pero
teníamos tanta convicción realmente con
el proyecto que estábamos entre manos
realmente contratamos a un equipo de
desarrollo sin tener nada de dinero para
realmente pagarlos porque es una mano de
obra bastante costosa y nos arriesgamos
realmente a contratar
en enero del 2018 en general 2018 con
estos famosos manteles ya habíamos
tocado mil puertas para ver cómo
hacíamos para levantar capital y bueno
estábamos como vueltos locos porque
teníamos el tiempo contrarreloj como
había dicho axel ya habíamos contratado
el personal y estábamos desarrollando un
envío de la aplicación por parte de un
demo y bueno dentro de tanto aroma de
martes para miércoles me acuesto a
dormir esa noche
empieza a soñar obviamente dormido y tal
y sueño con una persona con la que no
tenía mucho contacto y le digo a esa
persona mira tengo estos paquetes de
inversión que había comentado accede
pequeña mediana y grande inversión me
gustaría que tuviera el equipo este es
el proyecto para papá y ella dentro del
sueño y abro comillas aquí me responde y
me dice voy a invertir pero voy a
invertir con el mayor paquete de
inversión
al equipo
me despierto esa misma mañana de
miércoles lo primero que hice fue
escribir la chs lisa axel mira ya sé que
es una persona que va a invertir en el
pago directo nuestra socia va a ser
araceli entonces bueno ok tranca
axel me dice estás loco porque es una
persona con la que no teníamos tanto
contacto pero bueno
llamo a araceli inmediatamente digo mira
nacer y tengo este proyecto que te
quiero presentar bueno en cuanto corto
me dicen vamos a vernos el miércoles
vamos a irnos un viernes ese viernes
efectivamente nos sentamos les mostramos
los famosos mantelitos más un vídeo
corporativo que habíamos grabado y
vuelvo a abrir comillas porque me
respondió de la siguiente manera me dijo
voy a entrar pero voy a entrar con el
paquete de mayor inversión o sea de
hecho todavía lo cuente se me paran los
pelos fue tal cual así predestinado fue
el comienzo de pago directo
era básicamente yo de hecho recuerdo que
fue con algo escrito por un autor de
género de realismo mágico
así comenzó a pago directo
las piezas rompecabezas ya estaban
armadas ya tenemos el capital semilla
teníamos el equipo de desarrollo que el
más importante para ese momento del
proyecto que tenemos que desarrollar en
mi piel la aplicación pero como teníamos
una amplia gama de varios comercios que
podíamos atacar en ese momento en
caracas ocurrió un fenómeno caótico que
era unas colas interminables para pagar
las taquilla estacionamiento y realmente
conseguimos otro problema que teníamos
que buscar la solución que era el tema
del factor tiempo volvió a ocurrir el
mismo tema que había pasado marquen en
nueva york' y realmente no lo que
hicimos fue crear un vertical para el
estacionamiento donde nuestros
principales atributos eran una
aplicación que digitalizada y sustituye
al ticket físico entonces la aplicación
funcionaba de que tocaba un botón te
abría la barrera en la entrada te daba
un ticket digital y lo podías pagar
desde la aplicación ahí el usuario tenía
que pasar por las taquillas físicas para
pagar con punto de venta entonces
también hay sólo solventa vamos el tema
del tiempo el factor del tiempo
y al salir ya con tu ticket alado tocaba
un botón y te abría la barrera desde la
aplicación no solamente desarrollamos
una aplicación móvil sino también
desarrollamos un módulo que va en la
entrada y la salida con ingeniería de
inhouse que desarrollamos en house que
se llama mtd modulo de ticket digital
este modulo de ticket digital funciona
como un rock que como dispositivos
analógicos los convierten en inteligente
nosotros convertimos los
estacionamientos analógicos en
estacionamientos inteligentes
bueno tal cual de hecho axel lo que
comenta de los módulos y de la
aplicación fue así y me acuerdo que el
cst que es un centro comercial en
caracas para los que no lo conocemos
también este vídeo de otros países fue
el que nos brindó sus instalaciones para
que hiciéramos los laboratorios con pago
directo y bueno obviamente por estar
dentro del equipo yo fui uno obviamente
uno de los primeros en usar la
aplicación en tener la experiencia vivir
la experiencia de pago directo recuerdo
que se fue como que evocó algunos no sé
de memorias de infancia porque cuando
estoy en la salida y experimentando por
primera vez la aplicación me pongo junto
al módulo con la ventana de arriba
porque era una de las premisas que
teníamos por temas de seguridad de no
tener que sacar el teléfono del carro y
tal entonces le doy a abrir desde el
botón de la aplicación se sube la barra
y dije guau aquí hay un momento
importante sentí como si hubiesen hecho
un truco de magia esa sensación como que
bueno me sentía como con un poder no
obviamente esa sensación mágica como si
un mago estoy haciendo un truco o alguna
ilusión fue más bien como que el mago
era yo y bueno lo recuerdo tal cual en
ese momento porque sentí eso y bueno
después de tanto rollo nos dimos cuenta
que estábamos cumpliendo con la tercera
ley de clark que dice que cualquier
tecnología lo suficientemente avanzada
es indistinguible de la magia bueno
marque efectivamente un truco de magia
pero muy bonito todo pero como por arte
de magia se esfumó el dinero porque
teníamos teníamos presupuestados por una
cantidad de meses hicimos el envío de la
aplicación
podemos tener algún tipo de atracción
con los estacionamientos teníamos varios
asentamientos importantes en el país
pero realmente ya se iba acabando el
dinero y empezó ese problema en la
crisis económica medio se estaba
agudizando en el venezuela y empezar el
tema de los anaqueles vacíos las colas
interminables para comprar una harina de
trigo o de maíz
y bueno llega un momento un punto
insostenible que perdimos el equipo de
desarrollo perdimos toda atención al
cliente de hecho mark y yo éramos los
toreros de la aplicación en la empresa
hacíamos promociones en los
estacionamientos colocando en las
taquillas para digitalizar los tickets
físicos para que la gente conociera el
proyecto de esa manera pero bueno llega
un punto realmente insostenible eso duró
realmente durante casi todo el 2019 nos
endeudamos para pagar deudas o sea
realmente llegó todo un copo de nieve
que se va aumentando hasta hasta llegó
un punto que era realmente insostenible
pero bueno sabemos qué bueno que
sabíamos que en ese momento los
emprendimientos siempre podemos llegar a
ese valle de la muerte que es lo que se
le karate se le caracteriza y el apoyo
de nuestro inversionista capitalista
araceli nuestro familia en friends esté
claro que siempre nos apoyaba los
valores arriesgados que nos enseñó a
nuestros padres del echao p'alante
la resiliencia la perseverancia fue el
nuestro empuje de seguir día a día con
el proyecto y sabíamos que en algún
momento lo vamos a lograr
3 de diciembre del 2019 ya
obviamente todos saben cómo son los
diciembres y que uno quiere cerrar el
año de la mejor manera posible
empezó lo que nosotros denominamos un
efecto dominó ese día
un amigo al que le debíamos plata como
comenta bien que no había muchísimo para
sostener toda la empresa
un amigo se despertó y como le dije le
debíamos dinero recibe una llamada de
emergencia de económicas realmente la
emergencia económica estaba en todo el
país y esa fue la primera ficha en caer
de ese efecto dominó no que digo que
bueno obviamente él y yo coincidimos
todos los días en un café donde solíamos
desayunar y bueno yo me había despertado
ese día con un empuje yo creo que
realmente llevado por el estrés de saber
que ese ímpetu que un amanece bueno
vamos a echarle pichón como decimos en
venezuela
en let's go for it del casino entonces
fue todo un tema de qué bueno que nos
conseguimos ese día en el café el
llevado también por el estrés yo por
también éramos amigos pero bueno esa
conversación fue muy corta tensa y todo
lo que era un trato amistoso se perdió
en ese momento en pocas palabras y
aunque bueno otra vez somos amigos
bueno y al final esa fue la otra la
próxima ficha llame a otra amigo y le
dije mira yo te vendo mi carro él tenía
un concesionario de carro de ventas
usados entonces bueno en como una
cuestión como de media hora una hora fue
súper rápido terminé vendiendo el carro
sentí que fue como que me lo dicen
arrebatados bueno qué pasó aquí en qué
momento me quitaron el carro si tan
rápido pero bueno al final eso le iba a
dar un oxígeno a pago directo e iba a
pagar algunas deudas
pero bueno era mi herramienta de trabajo
también yo vivía lejos y
bueno efectivamente tuve que llamar a mi
hermano porque como dijo axel estábamos
todos hacíamos de toda la empresa y a mí
me tocaba hacer promoción de la
aplicación en un centro comercial al
sobre al sur de caracas que espacio
platillo y sabes que tienes que viajar
prácticamente para allá en medio lejos y
bueno no puedo ir a hacer la promoción
hoy porque bueno estoy en este tema le
dije mira vende el carro o sea que hay
que mantener la broma así de de esa
convicción teníamos de que íbamos a
lograr todo no entonces bueno
acto seguido llamé axel le dije mira no
voy para allá y axel me hizo el relevo
ese día bueno de hecho tranquila llamada
con marc de hecho me acuerdo que me
sentí muy mal porque porque además que
era mi socio era era mi hermano y bueno
sabemos que habíamos sacado algo de
fondo ahí ya vender llegar es que mueven
del su carro para pagar una deuda ya era
como que perder un poquito un activo y
y realmente nos afectó mucho ese momento
de nuestra vida
me acuerdo que bueno
habíamos tocado fondo pero teníamos esos
valores arraigados que previamente
mencioné que de la preservación y la
resiliencia que oye no te preocupes
mariotto yo voy a hacer el relevo ahí en
la promoción del paso latiguillo voy a
digitalizar los tickets y voy a
promocionar la aplicación de manera
normal de hecho yo estoy yo llegué
alrededor de las 6 de la tarde me
acuerdo que sale las horas picos de del
paseo latiguillo para las colas y cuando
yo estoy llegando viene un padre de
familia que venía saliendo de la función
la última función fin infantil de paso
del gatillo y él lo que viene bajando la
escalera le veo la cara de qué bueno que
estaba pensando en la cola que está que
se va a calar que por lo menos puede
estar una hora y en la cual para pagar
el ticket físico entonces yo estoy con
mi pendón
era algo muy rudimentario no tenía ni
esta ni nada algo fancy y yo empiezo a
vender a cada una de las personas que
estaban en la fila hasta que llegó a él
donde yo le explicó toda la
funcionabilidad de la aplicación él me
da su ticket físico y yo le creo un
ticket digital ticket digital alojado en
la aplicación la persona sale de la cola
va a la salida y sin bajarle el la
ventana en su vehículo le da a salir y
le abre la barrera
obviamente el asombro que vemos que fue
el mismo asombro que tuvo mar cuando lo
hizo la primera vez fue que nosotros
cambiamos lo que es un estacionamiento
aburrido un proceso que viene trabajando
desde 50 años con un ticket físico bajo
una taquilla algo que todo el tiempo es
lo mismo algo novedoso
en el asombro imagino que él busca la
manera de contactarme y llama atención
al cliente y en la atención al cliente
de la aplicación estaba mi número porque
eso en su momento éramos realmente todos
me llama yo estoy atendiendo a varios
usuarios y lo tienen doblemente medio
apurado y le di y me dice bueno mi
nombre es un se perdonamos tomate en
diste hace poco ahorita en paso de
látigo y yo soy un ejecutivo en el banco
un banco venezolano y yo quiero reunirme
contigo y si pudiera ser mañana es sería
excelente el icono de todo perfecto 6-6
mañana es vamos a estar ahí cuando
pienso eso pienso en quemar vendió su
carro y veo el efecto dominó que que fue
todo el día donde era noticia tras
noticias malas y veo que esta fue la
última ficha que nos volvía a sonreír
bueno al final
'hemos brincado mil obstáculos yo creo
que es una cuestión de perseverancia
como dice axel de siempre tener la
convicción de que los vas a superar
mucha gente nos dijo que estábamos locos
y llegó un momento que estábamos tan
grave que efectivamente nos tildaron de
locos pero bueno si han podido seguir
cronológicamente la historia eso pasó en
diciembre del 2019
tres meses después pasa lo que la
humanidad y el mundo jamás imaginó que
iba a pasar que fue el comienzo de la
pandemia todo el tema kobe pero bueno al
final de todo esto siempre con una misma
meta un mismo objetivo que era nuestra
pequeña obsesión o lo sigue siendo
todavía que es que la gente no pierda
más el tiempo siempre trabajamos con ese
factor ese elemento que es el tiempo
y después de tanto ver injustamente con
esta cachetada esta bofetada de realidad
que nos dio el coi
y nos dimos cuenta que no es una
cuestión de tiempo que realmente es una
cuestión de momentos
son esos momentos con los que tú puedes
pasar con un hermano con tu chamo con
tus hijos con tus padres con tu familia
con tus seres queridos
casualmente el momento en que nos llama
ted y nos invita a dar esta charla
ese fue el momento
en el que nosotros estamos viendo
nuestro último adiós con
nuestra asociada selling araceli se
había muerto justamente ese día
este momento nosotros lo que debemos
dedicar a ella para darle las gracias y
con disculpas
e
dar las gracias de verdad por todo por
todo el apoyo que nos dio
a nosotros y apago directo
todo es realmente todo lo que está
pasando en el mundo hay muchísimas cosas
que están pasando en este momento y todo
lo que hagamos en la tierra con el
tiempo que tenemos en la tierra tenemos
que hacer algo de valor con eso
cambien su tiempo por momentos muchas
gracias